especially at the time when
authoritarian regimes like russia and
china
challenge the rules based international
order
allies welcomed today's consultations
with president biden
ahead of his meeting with president
putin in geneva
our relationship with russia is at its
lowest
point since the cold war
and moscow's aggressive actions are a
threat
to our security nato remains
committed to our dual track approach of
defense
and dialogue will keep our defenses
strong
while remaining ready to talk to make
our positions clear
avoid misunderstanding and prevent
escalation
we fully support the decision to extend
the new start
treaty and we would welcome new
strategic talks
on future arms control
with a continued coordination here at
nato we stand in solidarity with our
valued partners ukraine and georgia
and we will continue to support the
reforms
bringing them closer to nato
at the summit today we addressed china
there is strong convergence of use among
allies
based on our interests we see
opportunities
to engage on issues such as arms control
and climate change but china's growing
influence and international policies
presents challenges to alliance security
leaders agreed that we need to address
such challenges
together as the alliance and that we
need to engage with china
to defend our security interests
we are concerned by china's coercive
policies
which stand in contrast to developmental
values
enshrined in the washington treaty
china is rapidly expanding its nuclear
arsenal
with more warheads and a larger number
of sophisticated sophisticated delivery
systems
it is opaque in implementing its
military modernization
it is cooperating militarily with russia
including
through exercises in the euro-atlantic
area
we also remain concerned about china's
use of this information
nato leaders called on china to uphold
its international commitments
and to act responsibly in the
international system
including in space cyber
and maritime domains in keeping with its
role as a major power
today leaders agreed our ambitious nato
2030 agenda
to ensure the alliance can face the
challenges and threats of today and
tomorrow
we took concrete decisions in eight
key areas first we agreed to enhance
nato as the transatlantic forum for
consultations and joint action
on all matters related to our security
and we agreed
to strengthen and broaden our political
consultation and coordination
second we agreed to reinforce
our deterrence on defense by
strengthening
nato as the framework for the defense of
the euro-atlantic area
and re-committing to the defense
investment pledge
we made in 2014. third
we agreed to strengthen the resilience
of our societies
with a new resilience commitment by nato
leaders
we will develop nato wide resilience
objectives
and concrete national goals to safeguard
our critical infrastructure fourth
we will sharpen our technological edge
allies have agreed to launch a defense
innovation accelerator for the north
atlantic
or bayano working with startups
industry and universities this center
will promote
transatlantic cooperation and help avoid
gaps among allies
allies also agreed to establish a nato
innovation
fund to invest in startups
working on emerging and disruptive
technologies
fifth we will step up our work to uphold
the rules based international order
to this end we will strengthen our
partnerships
with the asia pacific with australia
japan new zealand and the republic of
korea and
seek new relationships with countries
across latin america
africa and asia we are
also committed to the further a
deepening of our cooperation with the
european union
sixth we will substantially step up
training and capacity building for
partners
from ukraine and georgia to iraq and
jordan
seventh leaders agreed that for the
first time
addressing the security impact of
climate change
will be an important task for nato
this will include regular assessments of
the
impact of climate change on our
installations missions and other
activities
integrating climate change into our
exercises
defense planning and procurement and
developing a methodology
for assessing greenhouse gas emissions
from
military activities i am pleased to
announce that
all allies made a clear commitment to
significantly reduce
military emissions we also agreed to set
concrete targets
for nato to contribute to the goal of
net zero emissions by 2050
i also want to thank prime minister
justin trudeau and canada for offering
to host a new
nato center excellence on climate and
security finally we agreed
to develop nato's next strategic concept
in time for our summit in 2022
reaffirming our values and reflecting
the significant
changes in our security environment over
the past decade
the nato 2030 agenda sets a higher
level of ambition and it provides
a clear direction for the future
adaptation of our alliance
allies agreed that these decisions
must be underpinned by the right
resources
through national defense expenditure and
nato common funding this will be the
seventh consecutive year
of growing defense spending across
european allies and canada
with over 260 billion us dollars extra
on defense since 2014 allies are also
investing in new capabilities
and contributing to nato missions and
operations
all of this means fairer burden sharing
across the alliance
and we must maintain this momentum
to do more together allies agreed that
we also need to invest
more together in nato to resource our
requirements
in a more challenging security
environment
this will require increased resources
across all three nato budgets
military civil and infrastructure
for instance to support more joint
training and exercises
command and control stronger cyber
defenses
pre-positioned equipment better
infrastructure
and more capacity building for our
partners
so by agreeing the nato 2030 agenda
leaders have taken decisions to make our
alliance stronger and better fit for the
future
we also took decisions on our newest
operational domains
cyber and space allies agreed
a new cyber defense policy for nato
it recognizes that cyberspace is a con
is contested at all times and ensures
that we have strong technical
capabilities political consultations
and military planning in place to keep
our system
systems secure we also made clear
that nato is determined to defend itself
in space
as effectively as we do in all other
domains
land sea air and cyber
uh thank luxembourg for funding a
strategic space
situation awareness system here at nato
headquarters
we also addressed afghanistan after
almost 20 years nato military operations
are coming to an end we pay tribute
to all those who have lost their lives
or being wounded
and express our appreciation to all
those who have served
under the nato flag nato leaders
reaffirmed their commitment to continue
to stand with afghanistan
with training and financial support for
afghan forces and institutions and
funding
to ensure the continued functioning of
the international
airport so we have made important
decisions today
to make nato stronger in a more
competitive world
and shorter course for our alliance over
the next decade and beyond
and with that i'm ready to take your
questions okay we'll start with
reuters in the middle
over there do we have a microphone
yes please go go through thanks thank
you one uh secretary general on two
different points you mentioned
common funding you've often talked about
your ambitions can you
just clarify is there now an increase in
joint funding for military operations
and on a completely different subject on
afghanistan
was there an agreement today that one
nation
should take charge of the kabul airport
and was that turkey thank you
well the original proposal uh was to
uh only strengthen the uh the military
budget
uh the decision today is to increase uh
and strengthen all three of them
because there are three common funded
budgets in nato
this is a bill the civilian budget the
civil budget
then there is the the infrastructure
budget and then the
we have the military budget and uh and
you can uh and now the decision is to uh
to to also across all the three budgets
that we need to meet our high level
ambition
and that we need additional funding uh
to make sure that we
uh resourcefully the higher level
ambition we have uh
agreed um so this then applies for
all three budgets including activities
as higher readiness more exercises
more training better commander control
more investments in infrastructure
pre-positioned equipment
but also for instance uh over the civil
budget
to work with partners uh and uh and also
provide
uh support to partners in other ways so
so this is a this is
this reflects the entirety of the nato
2030
agenda and of course the important thing
is that we
agreed how we should strengthen and
adapt the alliance
by doing more together but if we're
going to do more together we also need
more
uh investments together and therefore i
welcome
uh that uh today we agree on
all three budget uh budgets not only uh
the military budget which
was the original proposal uh sorry there
was no
afghanistan well we are working
with our nato and allies are now working
on
uh uh how to ensure
uh uh the continued operation of an
international airport
uh in kabul uh uh there were meetings uh
also on the sidelines of the summit
today um uh turkey of course plays a key
role in those uh efforts
uh and we we we have not uh
we're not we are we are working on
exactly how to do it but it's a strong
commitment from nato
uh and from nato allies to uh ensure
that we can continue to operate an
international airport
that is important for for nato uh for
our continued civilian presence but it's
important for the whole international
community
and that's the reason why we really make
an effort to do so okay
we'll go to the end over there to dpa
please don't go forward go back yes
further further further carry on
two more and you're right thank you
perfect uh secretary general um
in the community in nato states that it
would like to maintain a constructive
dialogue with
china where possible
what are you going to do to have this
dialogue could it be an option to
propose
china a nato china council
or something like this thank you so
first of all we have
dialogue and contact with china uh today
on the military level
uh uh also on the diplomatic and
political level i met
the chinese foreign minister uh not so
long time ago so so we have
different way of of of maintaining
dialogue
uh with uh china uh and
and for instance on issues like arms
control but also
the situation afghanistan on the border
of china
of course these are issues where we have
a
common interest to look into how we can
can strengthen
our engagement and our dialogue i think
what you have to realize is that nato
has come a long way
um the first time we mentioned
china in a communique and a document in
decision from nato leaders
was 18 months ago at the summit in
london
before that we didn't have any language
at all in the current strategic
concept china is not mentioned with a
single word
now you can read a communique and you
see that we have seen a
convergence of use among allies uh where
we
of course again address uh uh
the importance of engaging uh china's
not an adversary
but also address the challenges uh
the the in investments in new modern
capabilities nuclear warheads
the coercive uh behavior uh and
also the challenges it poses to
international rules based order
and to our securities so so so if you
compare those documents
you see that we have come a long way to
develop a common position
uh on uh china and what it means for our
security
if we can add one more thing this is
very much about what we do at home and
this is about taking care of a core
responsibility to be able to protect and
defend all allies
against any threat from any direction
because we know that we see that china
is coming closer to us in cyberspace
we see them in africa we see in the
arctic we see them trying to control our
infrastructure we have the discussion
about 5g
and therefore what we do in nato 2030 is
highly relevant
also for how to address china
with more resilience with more
technology and
all the things we're now going to do
together okay we'll try to take
three questions over there to simplify
life for according to the microphone
we'll start with washington post in the
second row please
michael put up your hand please thank
you
thank you uh michael grinbaum from the
washington post thanks very much for
this
um can i just ask can you compare your
experience at this summit
uh with the u.s delegation to um
your experience with at summits with
president trump um and was president
biden
able to tell you anything that convinced
you that trump or another trump-like
figure won't be
back in the white house in a few years
and swing the united states back to a
more confrontational approach to nato
thank you it is different
then i think that the important thing
for me now is to convey a very clear
message
that was also conveyed in the meeting
today that
all allies welcome the strong commitment
from president biden to
nato and the bond between europe and
north america and nato
and that in return all uh the other
allies canada and europe
uh expressed the same strong commitment
that we
have to stand together in nato in a more
competitive world that's the important
thing i welcome that that was the
message from president biden
when i met him in the white house a week
ago and that's
the message from president boyd and his
administration today in the summit
then i would like to add the following
and that is that
i think what we learned over the
previous four years
was the importance of strong
multilateral institutions
in uncertain times because nato as an
alliance
as a as an institution goes beyond
individual
political leaders we can vet we can
weather
political uh wins and different storms
so if anything it just proves the
importance of building a strong
nato there will be
different political leaders elected in
many allied countries
in the years to follow but i am
confident that
as long as we realize that it is in our
security to us to stand together
national securities is to stand together
we will maintain nato as the bedrock for
our security
um and uh and uh also welcome the fact
that
uh we have very strong bipartisan
support in the united states
for nato uh but if you look at the
recent opinion polls uh
uh published from different sources over
the last weeks it
it confirms a very strong support for
nato in general both in north america
and in europe so
so i cannot tell you who will be the
next political leaders in
30 nato allied countries but i can tell
you that what we have seen
is that is the strength of strong
uh institutions like nato which can deal
with also
uh different political uh different
political
leaders that have different opinions
about uh
many issues as we have seen over many
years in nato
said if just behind washington post
thanks
hey matt everson cdfgmtv secretary
general you pointed out several times of
course the words coercive policies with
regards to china it's in the community
as well
so using harsher words than the g7
summit and i wonder
why is that is there a different
assessment and number two
other what are the lines that china
would need to cross in order to
be upgraded from a systemic challenge to
an
adversary or a threat
it's not for but
what matters for me is that we have a
united
uh and clear position uh among
30 allies on china
and uh and as i said this is to go a
long way for nato
because not many months ago we didn't
address that at all
and as always when 30 allies have to
agree
we need to to balance we need to
to address also some differences that
that's that's a
natural thing but the strength of nato
is that well
there are some differences we sit
together we work on the issues and we
come out with
strong unified clear messages
as we have done now uh so it's not for
me
to i will comment on the nato uh
statements uh i
i think they are clear and strong uh
we are not in the business of of
defining exact
lines but but we are just uh addressing
together
the fact that china is soon the biggest
economy in the world
though they had have the biggest uh uh
sorry the second biggest defence budget
and all the biggest navy and they are
investing heavily in new modern
capabilities including by
investing in new disruptive technologies
such as autonomous systems
facial recognition uh and artificial
intelligence and
and and and and uh putting them into
different weapon systems
that are really in the process of
changing the nature warfare in a way
we have hardly seen before uh or perhaps
ever seen before
and this matters for our security
there's no way uh
uh to deny that so the question is how
do we address it not
whether uh or if we're going to dress
okay we'll go to interface ukraine
second round here please
thank you anna uh secretary general
ukrainian
leadership has quite high expectation
regarding laboration action plan
but as far as i see from the
summit community we are not there yet
after this summit what will be your
main message for ukrainian leaders
and for ukrainian people thank you my
main message is that nato stand
in solidarity with ukraine uh we provide
a strong political support
to the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of ukraine
and we provide practical support and we
are stepping up our
practical support uh both within the
nato
as a context but also bilaterally
from different nato allies and had the
bilateral meeting for instance with
president
justin trudeau canada and of course
canada is one of many allies
who are providing bilateral support to
ukraine
uh um and and in the uh communique
in the decisions we have taken today we
have reiterated our
decisions on that nato's door is open
um uh uh on uh the decision we made
back in the at the summit in 2008
and uh also that we will step up uh and
that
will do more to help uh
ukraine and also georgia as another
aspen country to
uh focus on reforms that will move them
closer to
uh nato and the euro-atlantic
integration
okay we'll go to cbc so
one two three fourth row yeah thanks
secretary general murray brewster with
cbc thank you for taking the question
following on what was asked about
ukraine and the
membership action plan do you actually
ever foresee
any circumstances under which russia
would allow ukraine to join nato
uncontested and separately i wanted to
ask whether or not there was unanimity
among allies that china itself is a
security threat
i think it's extremely important to
underline that uh
the question every nation has
the right to choose his own path and um
and uh that includes also what kind of
security arrangements
it wants to be part of including whether
it wants to be part of a member of nato
or not
so the message is that
it is for ukraine and the 30 allies to
decide
when ukraine can become a nato member
russia of course have no say because
they
they don't they cannot veto what
neighbors can do
we will not return to an age where we
had
spheres of influence where big powers
decided what small neighbors could do
and i all they often use my own country
in the world as an example
norway is a a small country
bordering russia uh of course russia the
soviet union disliked that we joined
nato back in 49 1949
but but since allies at that time were
so strongly in favor of
accepting also small neighbors of russia
into the alliance uh
of course nowhere was accepted as the
baltic countries or as montenegro and
and north macedonia recently so um
so this is about fundamental principles
of accepting the right of every nation
to decide so it's for the 30 allies and
ukraine to decide when ukraine is ready
for a membership
well you can see the language we have
agreed
and and we addressed that china's
behavior the
coercive behavior uh the the the the
uh investments in new military
capabilities including nuclear systems
um uh uh and also
uh what they do regarding
international rules-based order all of
that
poses challenges to our security and
that's the reason why
we uh have uh the language we have
in the statement and a clear message in
the community but i would also say
that's the reason why we take the
concrete decisions
in the nato 2030 agenda because again
this is partly for instance about making
sure that we keep the technological edge
so when we established a technology
accelerator
it is about making sure that we keep the
technological edge in a world
where china is investing heavily in
these new modern technologies
when we are concerned about chinese
control over critical
infrastructure 5g airports
on developing
a challenge to our residents but
including also
potential challenges from china or when
you do more
both on cyber and space is also
something which is relevant for the
challenges we see stemming from
china lastly when we have agreed to work
more closely with uh
for instance uh australia japan
the asia-pacific countries that's also
about of course how to
respond to a a a more assertive china
we will go to emedi in the first second
row rather
right here
thank you very much mr secretary general
uh you have
spoken and mentioned uh open door policy
and
future enlargement of uh organization
after discussion with nato leaders can
you tell us more about
uh future membership of georgia and what
is the biggest stumbling block for
georgia's accession because the main
question now is in georgia is why is
georgia still
not in nato thank you very much
um the message is very much the same
as i just conveyed about
ukraine and that is that nato allah stan
in solidarity with georgia we provide
political support practical support
[Music]
we will never accept uh
that the parts of georgia are not under
georgian control
abkhazia and south ossetia and we
are stepping up our practical support
for georgia
including with the training center
outside obesity and in other
ways and allies are committed to
provide support and to
also uh make it very clear that uh
georgia is a highly valued partner uh
not least in the black sea region
uh and will continue to provide
practical support then
it is for the 30 allies
and georgia to decide when the time is
right
and we need consensus in this alliance
to to make
these decisions uh so i cannot give you
a date but i can
say that we will continue to support the
reform efforts
which are moving georgia closer to nato
okay we've got politico over there
thank you david herrera with politico
secretary general could we go back to
china for just a second
and i wonder if you addressed with the
leaders a concern we hear maybe from
some allies that one of the reasons
china hasn't appeared in
communiques all that often is that the
alliance has not yet given itself
the legal authority under the washington
treaty to operate outside the north
atlantic space and to envision
the necessity for treaty change and
should this be a notice
that in fact nato is prepared now to
operate anywhere in the world
outside the north atlantic space if it
perceives a threat
the first of all we operate outside uh
nato territory we have done that since
uh the end of the cold war
and that this was a discussion back in
the early 90s that's correct
someone said that either nato has to go
out to business throughout the area
and then we helped uh and then we
actually went out to area
we went into bosnia and sago and i
helped to end a brutal bloody war there
and a few years after went into also we
we
we we helped to end the the the
atrocities and the fighting in
in in in kosovo uh and then after 9 11
attacks
uh since then you've been at the
forefront of fighting
international terrorism and we have had
a big military operation
in afghanistan on the borders of china
so this idea that it's something
completely new that nato is going out to
area
is very strange because we've been out
of here for decades
but then back to my main message to
respond
to the challenges we see that china
poses to our security
is not about moving nato to asia it's
about very much about what we do at home
resilience technology cyber defense
because we see that china is coming
closer to us
there is no need for any change in the
nato treaty to respond to that
actually nato is going to do exactly the
same as we've done for more than 70
years
to protect and defend or allies against
any potential threats
you